notre invité principal
ce soir c'est hubert reeves bonsoir
bonsoir
alors et biarritz est ici ce soir pour
répondre à la question que tout le monde
se pose est ce que oui ou non c'est vous
aussi qui fait le père noël devant les
galeries lafayette
l'occasion alors urbain en p1 nous
serons tous les deux nous parlerons de
vous de vos origines votre parcours de
votre preuve de vos prix et vous nous
direz en tant qu astrophysiciens comment
vous trouvez miss univers
ça va mal pas mal et puis vous nous
parlerait de votre dernier livre publié
au seuil l'univers expliquer à mes
petits enfants voilà c'est vrai qu'aux
petits enfants vous a demandé d'où
venaient les pokémon
du japon à du jasmin d'origine japonaise
libéré il a réponse à tout l'émission
s'appelle salut les terriens
groupe g d'amandes forfait
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hubert reeves rebond soir en vous voyant
je suis toujours demandé si votre look
léonard de vinci chauffe barbe blanche
tout ça c'est du marketing ou c'est
juste une coïncidence ça je ne connais
pas la réponse avant alors vous êtes
l'astrophysicien le plus célèbre du
monde grand vulgarisateur du cosmos et
de ses mystères lauréat d'une multitude
de prix scientifique auteur de nombreux
ouvrages
vous avez été conseillé à la nasa
directeur de recherche au cnrs et vous
êtes président de la ligue roc pour la
préservation de la biodiversité
concernant la terre ne pensais pas que
ce serait plus facile de trouver une
autre planète que de sauver celle là
alors si on allait sur une autre planète
on risque de reproduire le même
comportement qui si oui il avoir les
mêmes problèmes si on n'a pas appris à
les régler ici ça va être pareil
ailleurs too bad
[Applaudissements]
le plus incroyable dans votre curriculum
vitae c'est qu'un astéroïde le
1993 est celle ci ce porte désormais
votre nom un big up
[Applaudissements]
le relais à un astéroïde à son nom avec
les filles c'est super parce que vous
dit tu vois pupella cette étoile c'est
la mienne oui
malheureusement il n'est pas visible à
la ligne du gabon aux
intérêts ce cap puissant aïe aïe aïe
alors vous êtes né le 13 juillet 1932 à
montréal votre père représentant en
chaussures mais pas très vrp d'un homme
froid distant obstiné courageux oui et
il avait une philosophie de la vie très
dure il disait c'est quand on affronte
la difficulté qu'on sait ce que l'on
vaut à vous savez tout vrai when the
ghost of the tough gasgogne c'est ça
c'était sa grande qualité quelle
chapelle si beaucoup il rentrait souvent
le soir sans avoir rien vendu il était
un peu fermé il n'avait pas beaucoup de
contacts avec ses enfants ou parce que
vous avez appris tout ce jeu c'est tout
et
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est tout à fait
car est alors votre maire s'appelait
manon beaux prés elle avait le sourire
de la joconde s'il s'explique quand on
voit à quel point vous ressemblez à
léonard de vinci
ça va de soi c'est pas par hasard c'est
quoi sourire c'est un sourire qui paraît
accueillant mais quand vous approchez
vous le sentez fois et entre votre
intérieur brit-brit c'était difficile en
plus ça a été très catholique très
bigorre
tout a fait d indulgence les vendredis
du mois les neuvaines tout ça
alors à 8 ans vous êtes mis au collège
avec vos frères lorsqu'un gros
sacrifices financiers pour vos parents
qui ne sont pas très aisée oui nous on
n'a pas beaucoup d'argent disait ma mère
mais on vous donnera en héritage de
l'instruction j'appelle ici ça au plur
poids bien sûr la preuve alors
heureusement dans cette vie un petit peu
triste quand même un peu un peu morne il
ya les vacances un espérances sur le lac
saint louis alors là votre père vous
amène voir la voûte céleste
la nuit nous amenait nous montrer les
étoiles les installations il racontait
des histoires
passionnant il vous offre les douze
volumes de l'encyclopédie de la jeunesse
et tout ça forme évidemment votre
curiosité alors pendant ses séjours
d'été il ya aussi votre grand mère
charlotte une extraordinaire conteuse et
qui vous apprend à broder à bien
raconter les histoires oui puis à les
aligner à les enfiler les unes dans les
autres à les mélanger avec oui oui elles
étaient tous les enfants du village
rappliquait quintin et racontait on
sortait les chaises elle pouvait parler
des arbres de temps à nous fascinait
mais surtout à espérance il ya un moine
trappiste
il s'appelle louis marie professeur de
génétique de botanique et là quand il
arrive votre mère si lénine en fait ce
louis marie et votre mère était fiancé
avant la première guerre est lui rentré
à la trappe pour éviter d'aller
combattre en fait voilà sa mère lui a
dit tu es mieux lac dal chemin des dames
le problème c'est qu'au monastère ce
louis marie a rencontré la vocation
est de brooke ne revient pas votre mère
l'a attendu pendant huit ans elle a fini
par épouser votre père qui était très
insistants d'ailleurs c'est très
romanesque oui c'est vrai
alors vous lui ressemblez 1-1
louis-marie d'abord physiquement mais
aussi par votre goût pour les sciences
c'est ce que je lui dois vous êtes
longtemps demandé si le mois n'était pas
votre père bah c'est une question qu
évidemment mes frères mes cousines me
taquinait cette question alors quand
vous demanderez ça à votre mère sur son
lit de mort nir a quand même un we ll a
nié mais qu'est ce que ça voulait dire
si elle avait promis jamais je ne le
dirais elle était dans une situation
délicate mais moi dans le fond ça mais
relativement également c'est pas pour
moi un grand problème ce que je retiens
de lui c'est ce goût de la science vous
de la connaissance ce que je tiens de
mon père c'est justement son courage
façon d'affronter les difficultés en
disant non vous savez à la churchill
ouais c'est tape du pied par terre et
non ouais ça j'admire les gens
qui ne cède pas parce qu'on peut dire
qui vous concerne n'est pas très sûr de
ce qui s'est passé au moment du big bang
alors vos études ne sont pas brillantes
vos notes sont même lamentable
oui et le déclic surviendra lorsque vous
devrez trouver à quelle distance placé
deux lentilles dans un télescope pour
discerner les astres avec netteté et
quand vous vous rendez compte que ça
dépend d'une simple formule algébrique
voilà vous êtes fasciné à j'étais
émerveillé de la puissance de l'esprit
humain
le vertige ça donne le vertige
et je me dis ah ben ça c'est un bon
métier moi j'ai envie de faire ça alors
de vos deux passions les sciences et les
mathématiques
vous ferez une combinaison avec la
physique l'astrophysique bac maîtrise
doctorat en astrophysique nucléaire un
tournoi elle est là vous rentrez la nasa
oui ce gérant comme professeur pour
former de futurs professeurs tonné
devant l'université américaine dans le
domaine de l'espace c'est la belle vie
la belle vie en avril boeing à notre
disposition on a mené les étudiants
faire le tour des points d'actes de la
nasa au carat canaveral pour voir un
lancement en californie palo alto rubin
voilà et du gpl tout ça ça c'était
vraiment ça et là au moment où vous êtes
un petit peu la cdu système
nord-américain qui et publie en péril
c'est à dire publish or perish nous
partons en europe oui j'ai une
invitation pour venir leur enseigner à
l'université libre de bruxelles demain
et je saute dessus et observer tous les
francophones hors hexagone ouais on en
rêve c'est de venir en france de venir
là paris ils ont lu victor hugo zola et
pour lui ce qu'un pays mythique mr pays
qui existe un et tout d'un coup vous
vous retrouvez à la place de la concorde
a partout cinq choses comme un rêve
qu'on arrive à réaliser va vous quitter
le québec trois ans avant la naissance
de célyne durand d'un hasard ou
ça je n'en sais rien football oui alors
vous devenez directeur de recherche au
cnrs et là vous qui avez toujours eu la
passion de raconter de transmettre vous
allez publier votre premier livre mais
c'est pas facile trente maisons
d'édition ont refusé de les refuser en
me disant l'astronomie ça n'intéresse
personne je leur mets dans un tiroir
dans dix ans ils en veulent pas tant pis
et c'est là que j'aime raconte jean-marc
lévy-leblond d'un éditeur au seuil qui
me dit écoute si tu as quelque chose à
publier ça m'intéresse voilà on y pense
qu'ils vont en vendre 3000 vous en
vendez 600 milles oui c'est plus même
non plus
et puis en mémoire des nuits à observer
la voûte céleste au lac saint louis vous
confondez pour la télévision la nuit des
étoiles chaque année est un événement
formidable une grande poésie c'est ça on
s'amusait beaucoup toute l'année avec
claude sérillon marie-odile monchicourt
il y avait une bonne ambiance grand
moment sympathique la nuit des étoiles
alors hubert votre dernier livre publié
c'est l'univers expliquer à mes petits
enfants paru aux éditions du seuil ce
livre est né de conversation avec votre
petite fille certains soirs d'été vous
dites c'est une sorte de testament
spirituel mais je le voyais un peu comme
ça moi je dirai à mes enfants mes petits
enfants pour qu'ils continuent à essayer
de faire connaître les découvertes
scientifiques en un rejet qui s'y
intéressent très intéressant on apprend
que le soleil en fait est une bombe
atomique au tout contrôler c'est
exactement la fusion contrôlée ce qu'on
avait à faire à iter points on sait pas
si on va y arriver là y arrivent très
bien ouais vous parlez des trous noirs
ou parler des multivers etc mais ce qui
est très étonnant dans votre bouquin
c'est que souvent vous répondais je ne
sais pas en fait oui ça c'était
important pour moi de faire passer ce
message il ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
sait pas et je suis aussi beaucoup sur
le fait qu'elle pose des questions
qu'elle réagisse la petite fille riche
je parle pour développer chez les
enfants une sorte d' indépendants 1 le
sens du doute je vais pas croire ce que
tu me dis simplement parce que citoyen
me le dit c'est un début de ce livre de
développer l'indépendance d'esprit chez
les jeunes il ya un truc que vous dites
pas c'est ça marche quand on voit une
étoile filante et qu'on fait un voeu ça
marche ça j'aimerais bien ouais
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu